der ist aber für viele Deutsche aktuell
von schweren Existenzsorgen geprägt auch
in diesem Monat wieder 8,7% Inflation
das sorgt für Entsetzen im Supermarkt
ein Blumenkohl für 4,99 € Quark und 72%
teurer Käse ja fast schon Luxus Essen
das trifft Familien aber vor allem auch
Rentner VdK-Präsidentin Verena Benzinger
schlägt Alarm vier von zehn Rentnern
kommt kaum über die Runde viele arme
Rentner hätten schon Mitte des Monats
nicht genug Geld für das
Lebensnotwendigste den Preissteigerungen
die Treffen Senioren besonders hat wir
sind natürlich keine Chancen hätten
etwas dazu zu verdienen sie seien Sie
eventuelle dazu eben oft zu alt oder zu
krank darüber sprechen wir jetzt hier
Frau Scholz in der Umfrage kam auch
heraus dass die alten sich von der
Politik im Stich gelassen fühlen über
70% sagen eigentlich die Politik die hat
uns gar nicht richtig auf dem Schirm ist
das ein Gefühl das sie teilen das teile
ich auf jeden Fall ja denn also gerade
auch wenn man sich ansieht die Situation
Personen im Pflegeheim zum Beispiel da
ist ja seit vielen vielen Jahren bekannt
dass es ein massiven Personalmangel gibt
und man hat immer wieder rumgedocktert
und letztlich aber nicht an den Ursachen
angesetzt und die sind offensichtlich
hinter vielen der der Heime stecken
sozusagen Finanzinvestoren die sich
wirklich die Taschen voll machen damit
und der Staat schaut zu also er
überlässt eigentlich sozusagen die alten
Menschen die vieles aufgebaut haben die
Kinder großgezogen haben die auch das
Land mit aufgebaut haben nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg eigentlich ja
sozusagen der Not dann nachher und ja es
ist ganz eine ganz schwierige Situation
und
auch gerade in der in der
corona-pandemie waren die die Menschen
in den Pflegeheimen also die die
besonders auch stark also sagen wir mal
belastet waren
alleine teilweise wurden sie krank oder
Sterbens alleine gelassen konnten sich
nicht verabschieden da sprechen wir auch
gleich noch mal ganz detailliert rüber
ich möchte zunächst bei diesem Thema
aber auch bei den Preissteigerungen der
Inflation bleiben sie sind Landrat aber
auch Landwirt Herr Schumann deswegen
würde es mich interessieren es kostet ja
nicht überall im Blumenkohl 4,99 €, aber
wie erklären Sie sich diese hohen
Preissteigerungen auch bei Gemüse wir
produzieren ob mein Vater produziert
Getreide Kartoffeln und wir haben
einfach durch den Krieg durch die durch
den
Sanktion eine Russland und insgesamt
auch ja immense Freistellung im
Düngemitteln gehabt und die schlagen
sich auch durch lässt sich auf die
Preise die wir brauchen um gewisse
Lebensmittel produzieren zu können aber
auch der der ruhepreis ist in der
Spieler mit und die Gemeinde die die die
gesamte unsichere Lage der Börse in
Landwirtschaft erleben wir das wir sind
quasi für die unser Geld an der Börse
wenn man verkauft man man guckt drauf
auf die Zahlen und da verdient man Geld
leider nicht auf dem Feld wie man sich
wünschen würde sondern im Büro und guckt
auf den Ticker wie die Preise sich
entwickeln und dann verkauft man und das
ist das gesamte Problem was auch der
Markt widerspiegelt wo Unsicherheiten
Preissteigerungen verursachen die
wirklich eigentlich gar nicht auch
teilweise notwendig sind glauben sie
damit nutzt der ein oder andere diese
Preissteigerungen auch für sich aus also
man kann sich ja kaum erklären warum
jetzt ein Blumenkohl 499 kosten sollte
die ganz stark von aus wir haben es bei
uns damals auch erlebt als die
Mehrwertsteuer abgesenkt wurde 19 auf 7%
und so weiter sind bei teilweise bei den
erzeuge Preisen oder bei der
Verkaufspreise für die Endverbraucher
die Preise auch so geblieben und sind
nicht zurückgestuft worden ich denke
schon dass es auch hier in der Branche
auch schwarze Schafe gibt und sollte da
der Staaten besseren Blick darauf haben
insgesamt sollte der Staat sich aus dem
Markt raushalten denke ich das wäre die
die die richtige Weise Antworten er
musste da agieren wo er es kann wo es
Sinn macht wir haben es gesehen bei den
Benzinpreisen hat das wenig Sinn gemacht
ganz viel Geld hat er gekostet insofern
da wo er es kann so das machen aber
generell sollte sich der Staat aus dem
Markt raushalten
auch Herr schmier ganz klar eine
wahnsinnige Belastung für die Seele
Existenzängste man weiß überhaupt nicht
Mitte des Monats ist Rentnerin oder
Rentner und weiß nicht kann ich
überhaupt am Ende des Monats mir noch
was zu essen kaufen ich weiß diese
Probleme können wir können Sie es an
diesen Tisch nicht lösen aber wie geht
man mit solchen Existenzängsten um die
einen ja teilweise um den Schlaf bringen
also man muss erstmal die Situation
ernst nehmen und ich glaube dass gerade
auch diese ältere Generation viel
souveräner damit umgeht weil sie
möglicherweise auch Entbehrung schon
erlebt haben hingegen die jüngere
Generation wirklich ausflippt und am
belastungslimit ist weil sich massive
Sorgen über das was kommt macht und
gleichzeitig ohnmächtig sind und wenn
das zusammen kommt Sorge und Ohnmacht
dann sehen wir einfach das was wir jetzt
erleben die Psychiatrien überlaufen die
einzige Situation die wir bei Corona die
Trias war das keine Plätze mehr für
Kinder und Jugendlichen die belastet
sind vorhanden sind und deshalb ist es
wichtig in der Kommunikation mit den
Eltern in den Schuhen ein bisschen mehr
Gelassenheit Menschen zu lehren und zu
vermitteln weil es ist möglich auch in
schweren Zeiten souverän zu sein das hat
die Kriegsgeneration den Zweiten
Weltkrieg erlebt immer wieder bewiesen
und wir müssen alle nicht so hysterisch
durch die Welt laufen auch wenn die
Ängste von manchen ernst zu nehmen sind
ein bisschen mehr Gelassenheit hilft
dann können wir häufig von alten
mehrlernen als wir denken gleichzeitig
hat der Umfrage über 70 Prozent der
Rentnerinnen und Rentner haben wirkliche
Sorgen es ist ja enorm das ist eine
enorme Zahl wenn man sich denkt dass so
viele Menschen mit solchen sorgen durchs
Leben gehen was raten sie da was kann
man machen es ist ja vor allem auch eine
Generation die vielleicht jetzt nicht
unbedingt immer zum Psychologen zum
Psychiater gegangen ist das Problem also
wenn die die tatsächlich die diese
Menschen sehen und ernst nehmen das ist
das eine aber dann muss man einfach mal
gucken was tun ich tagtäglich für mich
um tatsächlich mit einem guten Gefühl
ins Leben zu starten also ich weiß das
von meinem Opa noch der hat morgens mit
einem heute wird man sagen
dankbarkeitsmeditation den Tag begonnen
er hat dann das morgen Gebet aber begann
der Tag damit dass man sich erstmal zehn
Sachen klar gemacht hat wofür man
dankbar ist und wir haben teilweise
diese Perspektive für die Fülle verloren
und das hilft in dem Moment wenn du
wirklich kein Geld mehr hast in dem
Moment nichts aber ganz viele die diese
Stimmung anheizen die sollten einfach
mal hingucken was ist noch da und vor
allem auch die Kinder der Senioren
sollten emotional Anfüttern das heißt
durch Nähe durch echtes Interesse am
Menschen schaffen wir gemeinsam schwere
Zeiten besser zu verstehen ja das da
auch die Familien mehr zusammenrücken
gleichzeitig hat das angesprochen wir
haben so viele haben da auch das
Vertrauen einfacher verloren junge wie
alt man fragt sich wirklich er hat die
Regierung die Inflation im Griff sind
diese Preissteigerungen wirklich auch
bei den Politikerinnen und Politikern
angekommen dafür müssen einmal
festhalten dass am Ende eine Regierung
zwar Inflation beschleunigen kann durch
die Art und Weise wie sie Politik macht
am Ende aber die Kernaufgabe der
Europäischen Zentralbank ist für ein
stabilen Euro zu sorgen und da sehen wir
einfach massive Versäumnisse das kann
man auch gar nicht laut genug sagen das
muss man auch immer wieder an Frau
lagart adressieren dass dort in den
vergangen anderthalb Jahren einfach
getrödelt wurde und einfach der Job den
die EZB hat nicht gemacht wurde ich
erinnere nur an den Herbst 21 deutlich
vor dem Krieg als wir bei Bild
beispielsweise Experten bei uns gesagt
haben achtung da baut sich was auf die
EZB muss handeln ich erinnere mich dass
der Commerzbank das beispielsweise sehr
stark adressiert hat dass das auch der
Chef der Deutschen Bank sehr stark
adressiert hat und ähm wir bei Bild von
der Europäischen Zentralbank im Dezember
21 dafür kritisiert wurden es gab auch
andere Experten die gesagt haben was
Bilder macht es Panikmache und was ist
passiert im letzten Jahr musste dann die
Europäische Zentralbank die Chefin
selbst einräumen das offenbar ihre
inflationsmodelle nicht ganz richtig
sind und das ist eigentlich ein
Alarmzeichen dass diejenige Bank die
verantwortlich ist für den Euro
für diesen großen Währungsraum sich
offenbar mehr mit grünen Investitionen
beschäftigt hat als mit ihrer
Kernaufgabe nämlich Inflation zu
bekämpfen das ist eine totale Verfehlung
dessen was sie eigentlich machen muss
deswegen da ist die Hauptaufgabe zu
suchen die EZB hat mittlerweile
geschneit weniger beim Start aber der
Staat kann natürlich zu sich
entflationstreiber sein und das ist auch
ganz klar das darf natürlich nicht sein
und zumindest auch den Menschen und das
sagt ja diese Umfrage auch das Gefühl
geben wir sehen euch und offenbar ist da
ein ganz großer Vertrauensverlust
entstanden wenn über 70 % sagen wir
fühlen uns komplett im Stich gelassen
wenn wir Menschen in Deutschland haben
Rentnern und Rentner die in der Mitte
des Monats nicht mehr wissen wie zahle
ich eigentlich das Lebensnotwendigste
das darf doch nicht sein das darf nicht
sein und wir wissen natürlich dass der
Staat auch man sagt das immer so leicht
aber die Bundesregierung beispielsweise
aber auch die Länder und die Kommunen
natürlich von Inflation profitieren und
zwar beispielsweise durch die
Mehrwertsteuer überall da wo ein Prozent
drauf kommt ist es gut wenn Preis
steigen weil automatisch dann die
Einnahmen aussteigen und wenn wir sehen
welche Debatten ist auch im letzten Jahr
gab über die Frage gibt es eigentlich
etwas zurück für die Steuerzahler also
die Berufstätigen in dem Sinne dass der
Einkommensteuersatz angepasst wird da
sind mir viele Rufe von SPD und Grünen
noch in Erinnerung die gesagt haben
wollen wir doch nicht so richtig machen
das sehen wir eindeutig wie sehr sich
auch Personen in der Bundesregierung
bestätigt fühlen von dieser Inflation
sich daran nicht persönlich aber
sozusagen als Gemeinschaft bereichern um
das Geld zu nehmen und irgendwo zu
verteilen aber meist auch oder vielfach
nicht bei denen die es dann dringend
nötig hätten würden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung es kann
nicht wahr sein jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie